cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get 15 off at
cheesebutter.com pacman the link is down
below
welcome everybody so i want to start
today by spending some time on the
question what is a woman and it might
seem like kind of well you know what is
a banana what is an apple it might seem
kind of out of the blue
but this is a topic that came up last
week during the confirmation hearings
for joe biden's supreme court nominee
katanji brown jackson and we saw
republican senator marsha blackburn ask
among a number of other bad faith
questions
can you give me a definition for a woman
and here's how that went
uh can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not in biology
and after that all took place last week
i appeared on the right-wing daily wire
show hosted by michael knowles and we
could have talked about anything but he
wanted to talk about
what is a woman do i have a definition
for a woman and i explained to him
that this is a bad faith question
that any answer that judge jackson could
have given
would have allowed blackburn to push her
into a corner about this or that
particular situation
and that the reality is in jackson's
role as a supreme court justice some
general definition of a woman won't
really do anything to help figure out
difficult cases since courts have to
adjudicate specific
and narrow legal issues
in particular situations based on
individual complaints brought to a court
but now that we got that all out of the
way i actually do want to talk about
with you what is the definition because
while most people understood the bad
faith nature of the question
there are people who have reacted and
who have emailed me and have said you
know
the definition is so easy
but it's actually not even going by
their simple definitions and i hope that
we can explore
why this is just a bad faith and
unproductive line of discussion and
reasoning now before i get into this i
do want to remind everybody particularly
people who might see this segment hear
this segment and not know me
everything i'm saying here is my best
faith analysis of the situation
and it is with me speaking as an
unfettered defender of trans rights who
understands that this is not a simple
situation and understands the bad faith
nature of why the right keeps saying
give us a definition for woman so ryan
wrote to me
and he explained
david here's why these things are so
tough and meaningless in the abstract
let's say i ask you to define life okay
that's pretty easy right i'll look it up
in the dictionary and let's start with
the dictionary definition why not so a
dictionary definition for life is quote
life the condition
that distinguishes animals and plants
from inorganic matter
including the capacity for growth
reproduction functional activity and
continual change preceding death
great so now i've bought in
i've picked the definition and that's
what blackburn wanted all the
republicans wanted right
was just pick a definition and give us
that definition but wait a second
are children not life david because they
that was in your definition reproduction
and they can't reproduce
yet
oh that's right that wasn't my
definition what about the elderly who no
longer grow
and who also no longer reproduce oh no
no problem let me tweak the definition
now i've got it i'm gonna get to it okay
the definition is to account for people
who are too young or too old to
reproduce let's have a new a different
definition of life
it's the condition of an organism
that ever had
or will have
that capability of reproduction and
growth then it's life that's tough
that's tough some people are born
without ever having the capability for
reproduction a man with a sperm disorder
kleinfelter syndrome a woman with
certain conditions damn okay all right
well let me walk it back again so i say
what matters is the species as a whole
if this is a species that as a whole
reproduces even if individual members
for whatever reason might not be able to
then that meets the definition of life
oh no what about mules a mule is what
happens when you breed a female horse
and a male donkey
and they're sterile as a species they
can't reproduce
mules aren't alive now based on my
definition
so you can very quickly see how this
just define it just give us a definition
it's not only bad faith
in theory but it's also really tough in
practice so now let's apply it to the
question of what is a woman
during our interview
michael knowles suggested a few
definitions and one of them check out
the interview if you're interested one
definition he said was it's
anything and anybody that isn't a man
well 1.7 percent of the population is
born intersexed meaning with both
genitals or with some ambiguity in terms
of the genitalia so if you say if it's
if if they're not a man they're a woman
that definition doesn't account for that
it doesn't work
then nulls said well it's a human that
produces eggs
so a lot of conditions including
hormonal imbalances and thyroid
conditions things in the womb pituitary
tumors that prevent some women from
producing eggs or being able to
reproduce well what about
capability of reproduction through
pregnancy a human with the capability of
reproduction through pregnancy tons of
conditions that inhibit reproduction and
then you've got post-menopausal women
that can't reproduce but are they not
women very few people would argue that
so the point here is these definitions
do not work for determining
who is a woman
since not all biological women are able
to do these things not all biological
women menstruate for different medical
reasons
imagine defining men
simply by their ability to i don't know
impregnate someone or have an erection
so now let's come around to the question
that is actually underlying all of this
for many republicans because
you have to really understand the
political angle here
they have started to take this
perspective
that anybody can simply assume an
identity
and then
tell a court i was discriminated against
on this basis and ted cruz kind of
brought this to the absurd during the
hearings in order to make an analogy and
ted cruz said well could i as a hispanic
man for an hour say i'm now an asian man
and then sue harvard for anti-asian
discrimination if you can say i'm a
woman now i'm a man why can't i say well
now i'm asian
it sounded kind of nuts
but he said it and here's the clip but
the question
let me ask under the modern leftist
sensibilities if if
i decide right now that that i'm a woman
um
then
apparently i'm a woman does that mean
that i would have article 3 standing to
challenge a gender-based restriction
senator to the extent that you are
asking me about
who has the ability to bring lawsuits
based on gender those kinds of issues
are working their way through the courts
and i'm not able to comment on them okay
if if i can
change my gender if i can be a woman and
then an hour later if i decide i'm not a
woman anymore i guess i would lose
article 3 standing
tell me does that same principle apply
to other protected characteristics for
example i'm i'm an hispanic man could
could i decide i was an asian man would
i have the ability to be an asian man
and challenge harvard's discrimination
because i made that decision
senator i'm not able to answer your
question you're asking me about
hypotheticals and um
i'm asking you how you would assess
standing if i if i came in and said i
have decided i identify as an asian man
i would assess standing the way i assess
other legal issues which is to
listen to the arguments made by the
parties consider the relevant precedents
and
constitutional principles involved and
make a determination now of course
we all know that that's silly but why is
it silly
it's because whatever it means to be
asian
ted cruz isn't actually
living life as an asian man which sounds
a little silly when it comes to race but
will then apply it to gender and
importantly society doesn't see ted cruz
as an asian man now i know you can say
but david that's based on stereotypes or
whatever but it gets to something very
important here when we think about under
the law
when i think about like genitals aside
who can bring a lawsuit for gender
discrimination because the whole idea
here is they they love to say can a guy
put a wig on and then sue and say i was
discriminated against for being a woman
um
the
reality here
is that when we say who can say i was
discriminated against for being a woman
what i imagine is anyone living
outwardly as a female and seen by
society as a female
could bring a lawsuit for gender
discrimination as a woman now i know
it's not perfect but understand that
this is the legal question i know
republicans love to say
you know men with wigs they said man
with a wig hangs out in a bathroom
they're doing all sorts of things and
the point they make is a man with a w
with a wig who doesn't actually live
life as a woman nor is seen by society
as a woman
they're going to have a very hard time
showing in court
that they were discriminated against
for their status as a woman it's going
to be very difficult to show that now
this is not about should we call people
by the pronouns they want to be called
by of course of course that's this is
about the legal question can anybody men
women whoever say i was discriminated
and discriminated against for being a
woman so think about it if i put on a
wig right i wear my current clothes
i have my current voice
i go by the name david
if i do all the things that socially tag
me as male
no court
is going to accept that i was
discriminated against because of the
perception that i was a woman
i could go and do all the things right i
could go to the dmv and say i i want to
be seen as i want to be female now i
want f on my uh license
i could i could do all those things but
if i sue
i'm not going to be able to show that i
was seen as a woman and that is
paramount to proving that you were
discriminated against for gender reasons
now on the other hand
if a trans woman is seen as a woman in
whatever situation they're suing over
and they can show that
why shouldn't they be able to bring such
a lawsuit i mean think about it in many
states you can be fired
for your real or perceived sexual
orientation even if you aren't a gay man
if you're fired because your boss is
homophobic and thought you were gay
you can sue even though you're not
actually a gay man
and similarly the point here is when
they talk about anybody can just sue and
say i was discriminated against because
i'm a woman well
can you actually show anybody believed
you were a woman in the sense of how
they related to you and their alleged
discrimination so the big point here is
when right wingers ask this stuff number
one it's obviously in bad faith
number two
whatever you say is going to be used
against you but number three
it's actually a lot more complicated
than they pretend these definitions to
be
if we think about it from a legal
standpoint and we talk it through we
actually can make quite a bit of headway
so let me know your thoughts and
hopefully we've touched on what are some
of the
really underlying issues and questions
here
that that exist
i got dozens of emails from people over
the weekend um uh not over the weekend
since last night
saying david you've got to talk about
what happened at the oscars will smith
open hand slapping
a chris rock
and it was crazy and you've got to talk
about what happened so we are going to
talk about this on the bonus show today
i wanted to say just a couple of things
about it
i am not let me first explain what
happened
as i understand it and i haven't watched
the oscars in more than 10 years but i
watched some clips and read some
articles this morning
chris rock joked about
will smith's wife's short haircut jada
pinkett smith which is apparently short
at least in part because of the medical
condition alopecia baldness
and will smith
apparently didn't like it and when he
walked up to the stage he slapped chris
rock
and then when he sat back down he was
screaming at him about
keep my wife's name out of your mouth
the reactions exploded some people
reacting along racial lines saying that
if this was
rather than two black men a white man
and a black man it would have been seen
completely different
uh
one of them would have been arrested or
the other would have been arrested okay
that was one line of analysis another
was this was obviously staged because in
no sane world would this happen
and then the oscars just continue i
don't know that that's necessarily the
case the people organizing the oscars
might have been as shocked by what
happened as anybody else and they didn't
know what the hell to do and they're
like i guess we just continue the show
um i i really don't know at this early
point in time
what the truth is
about this
but uh it is one of the strangest things
i've ever even heard of happening during
the oscars and we are going to talk
about it in more detail on the bonus
show so i just wanted to say a little
something i want to hear from you if
you're watching on youtube leave a
comment about what you think happened
was this genuine was this a setup as
summer claiming uh let us know let me
know on twitter at dpakman and then
we'll talk about it on the bonus show
one of our sponsors today is cheese
butter giving you 15
off i love this stuff cheese butter is a
delicious gourmet cheese melt that
ingeniously blends
four indulgent cheeses and aromatically
seasoned butter
all the ingredients the cheese the
butter the seasonings are sourced for
the highest quality you can really taste
that this was made with fresh simple
high shelf ingredients nothing
artificial
cheese on bread right i mean come on and
butter on bread
why wouldn't i love cheese butter put it
on french bread sourdough bagels english
muffin jewish rye pumpernickel
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli veggies
cheese butter is a business that
supports the david pakman show support
them their product is really fantastic
it's been a secret recipe in their
family for 50 years
taste it for yourself to really
understand what it's about
i don't think you'll be sorry
cheese butter is giving my audience 15
off
when you go to
cheesebutter.com
pacman
all right this uh you are not going to
believe i would say unless you've been
following politics in the united states
and in which case you won't even find it
surprising
so-called pro-life republicans
self-described pro-life republicans are
now debating whether
women who have abortions should be
killed
really supportive of life aren't they
this is happening in uh texas this is
happening within the republican party in
texas in suburban fort worth house
runoff republicans debate killing women
over abortion the best way to create and
foster a community that supports life
is to kill women who had abortions what
should texas punish abortions by putting
teenage girls and women to death or not
writes yahoo news that's the current
debate of the republican party of texas
where outlawing abortion is no longer a
question of if or when but a question of
whether to kill women for getting one
listen to this they want us to believe
they are pro-life north richland hills
republican david lowe swears his
campaign in the may 24 runoff election
has nothing to do with killing women i'm
not even a fan of the death penalty he
said but then he went on to praise a
house bill that would have made ending a
pregnancy a potential capital crime now
understand that in texas
capital crimes can be punishable by the
death penalty you have an abortion
you're charged with a capital crime
you could be given the death penalty for
that capital crime
do we all agree abortion is murder
he asked the crowd
absolutely
there should be consequences for it
of all the opponents low an afghanistan
war veteran
chose to run against district 91 state
rep stephanie click
click a 35-year nurse has been a low-key
house leader
in texas is one step at a time effort to
end abortion
texas has reduced
remember legal abortions by about 10
percent abolishing abortion is important
but we can do that without giving women
the death penalty the death penalty
they are debating in texas should women
be killed
if
they have an abortion
uh you may remember
um
that
another texas republican lawmaker is
attempting to make abortion punishable
by the death penalty as reported a few
weeks ago by the texas tribune this
legislation was filed about uh three
weeks ago by state rep brian slaton it
does not include exceptions for rape or
incest it does exempt ectopic
pregnancies that threaten the life of
the woman but this is a bill that would
abolish and criminalize abortions and it
would leave both the women and the
physicians who performed the procedure
to face criminal charges that could
carry the death penalty
they're for life guys
and so if a woman has an abortion
you kill the woman
and you kill the doctor
think about that
now donald trump you may remember kind
of stepped into this the inic trump was
pro-choice his whole life trump was
pro-choice 68 years
then he became a republican and ran for
president so of course he had to say i
had an epiphany i had an awakening and
now
i'm against abortion but trump didn't
know the anti-abortion talking points so
when being interviewed by chris matthews
in 2016 trump was asked should there be
a punishment for the women and he said
yes remember this do you believe in you
do you believe in punishment for
abortion yes or no as a principle and
the answer is that
there has to be some form of punishment
for the woman yeah it has to be some
form a fine
imprisonment for a young woman who finds
herself pregnant have to be determined
wow do you believe
the next day
trump had to walk that back because the
republicans explained to him no no no no
we're against abortion but we don't say
punish the woman that's too far for us
in 2016.
now in texas it's a serious debate
absolutely horrifying stuff
we are going to take a tour today
through three elements of the current
american right wing and we're going to
go through them from the top down and
it's going to be about this movement
called trumpism we it starts with trump
then it goes to other elected officials
who are just as wacky or wackier and
then it goes to the people that follow
them and we're going to be able to see
all of this through a rally in georgia
that donald trump held over the weekend
we're going to look at what trump said
we're going to look at what other
republicans said and we'll look at what
rally goers said so we're going to start
here first with donald trump i want to
remind you
very small crowd
this was the smallest trump rally crowd
in georgia in six years
barely 5 000 people trump always says
there's 50 000 people here he said at a
recent rally there were 87 000 people
there there weren't those are just lies
but it is true that trump used to get 10
to 20 000 people at these rallies barely
5 000 people entire sections with very
very empty seats so understand that
context let's jump right into the first
clip where donald trump seems to be very
clearly saying i'm running i'm running
in 2024 but he also says he's already
won twice
i ran twice
i won twice
and i did much better the second time
and now
we just may have to do it again
imagine being this excited
this excited that the guy who lost your
party everything he lost the white house
after one term
he oversaw republicans losing the senate
he oversaw republicans losing the house
they lost everything under trump and
they want more it's like a comedy show
at this time
except it's not
then
this is a classic trump unintelligible
rant it's something about gas prices
but trump is visibly confused he
glitches i can't make heads or tails out
of what he's saying because energy is so
expensive today a gallon you take a look
at your forget about it the pump you
take a look at a barrel now it'll be two
dollars it could be people are saying
it's going to go up to
if think of this
people are saying
oh man a barrel might go all the way up
to three bucks that that would be the
best deal on a barrel i could imagine
per barrel this is going over a hundred
dollars it's going over 150 it's going
up to 200 and 250
so we're making these countries by the
way they cut to a vietnam veteran who
seems as confused as anybody in the
crowd look at the look on this guy's
face uh okay so
it does not
appear that any of what trump is saying
is is going to happen um
oil went up it got to about 125 it came
back down it may go up a little bit
again but
what trump is saying is just doesn't
make any sense whatsoever trump also
back to saying putin is smart he's going
he's he's going back to putin as smart
[Applause]
but they asked me is putin smart yes
putin was smart and i actually thought
he was going to be negotiating i said
that's a hell of a way to negotiate put
200 000 soldiers
on the border it should have never
happened
certain things and that thing would have
ended but they didn't have the common
sense they didn't know what to do we
wouldn't have even had to give him
i think he got
he made a big mistake i think he made a
big mistake all right so it's it's
completely unintelligible what sort of
point donald trump is trying to make
there then trump told one of these sir
stories where he says they they said sir
but this story is the opposite of
relatable trump says because of the
supply chain issues tiffany is out of
rings which the crowd really can relate
with
who the hell ever heard of this stuff
you go to the stores in the sorcerer the
cupboards are empty
you go into tiffany and where is your
ego sir we think we can have it in the
next uh seven to eight months oh that's
wonderful
the good news is you don't buy anything
you save a lot of money okay yeah and of
course trump's uh trump's crowd that's a
common problem they're trying to buy
rings at tiffany and they're on
backorder that's a really really common
problem trump did address these
confirmation hearings of judge katanji
brown jackson and this is beyond parody
trump says that jackson
was disrespectful
to the republican senators if you can
imagine that but judge jackson
was unbelievably disrespectful to
republican senators what that in many
cases were really nicely
asking questions
she had total disdain and even hatred
for them and
i understand that she's very proud of
the fact that she never once voted
to support president trump on anything
she always
yes they were very nicely asking
questions like are babies racist
are you soft on people
convicted for a child molestation or for
explicit images of children can you
define a woman
and other similarly respectful questions
i mean quite literally you could just
you hear trump and then you go okay the
opposite of that that must be what is
true also this is a clip that reminds us
how desensitized we are
to the absurdity of what trump now says
where um he can now
essentially say
other governors haven't helped me with
the coup
and it doesn't even really make
headlines anymore
but he had no
chance
at the time in his opinion against
stacey abrams he was going to beat him
and then he asked me to get involved and
i had two rallies like this 52 000
people at each at the airport i said
brian you're gonna win
and he said i don't think so sir
i said you're gonna win brian i don't
think so sir i don't think i can beat
her
i said brian look at this crowd but
they're here for you and you know what
it's true they weren't here for him they
were for me
and he ended up winning
twice
okay he ended up running and then when
we needed help
he wasn't there for
this country and it was for the country
he wasn't there
but the bad news is
he wasn't there to help me with the coup
that's an insane thing for a former
president to say and we are so
desensitized to it that that didn't even
make headlines two more quick clips here
of course trump is the perfect victim he
is the one treated the most unfairly
everybody's so mean to trump
now
no president has ever suffered like i've
suffered at the hands of these animals
people say to me how the hell did you do
it and i can't even give him an answer i
don't know
i think i did it
because i love you and because we have a
job to do nobody has ever been treated
this unfairly and then last clip
it is march almost april of 2022
hillary clinton has not been a candidate
for almost six years
and their chanting locker up
i'm suing for millions of dollars in
damages against crooked hillary clinton
james comey andrew mckay
the two lovers who remember the lovers
peter strzok and lisa fay
and they're going around suing everybody
they use the fbi's web that was not a
good idea
they use the fbi servers
their for law order their for due
process and yet they say lock someone up
who hasn't even been charged with a
crime
this is a very sick group of people but
remember trump's only part of it after
the break we'll look at his acolytes who
spoke at the rally and then we'll look
at the rally goers which are i would
argue just as bad and potentially even
more dangerous so we'll take a quick
break we'll have all of these clips on
our instagram at david pakman show and
we'll be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
okay so we did part one of this wacky
georgia weekend wherein we looked at
donald trump's speech at a rally in
commerce georgia but i told you there
would be three parts we'll eventually
get to the rally attendees but first i
want to do something intermediate which
is to look at some of the people on the
stage some of the other people who
participated in the rally because at uh
very often at these rallies we say
you've got the craziness of trump and
you've got the craziness of the rally
goers but here we actually have really
in its full glory
the level of delusion and depravity of
the people that still are willing and
interested in associating themselves
with donald trump including candidates
and current elected officials and so
let's go through some of those first and
foremost radical georgia congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene was at the rally
she spoke at the rally and before
speaking she was interviewed and uh here
she puts together
some outrageous uh idea
that they if they take this the house
will investigate hunter biden's laptop
now hunter biden has nothing to do with
the administration i don't know why
anyone's still talking about his laptop
but take a listen to this and they were
doing all these shady business deals in
ukraine and other countries
what they were doing is investing in bio
labs interested in bio weapons and my
team is already looking into it and i
have to tell you we had our republican
retreat for the past couple of days and
there's going to be a new republican
party coming back in washington and
we're playing oversight committees on
every single committee there will be
oversight investigations and you better
bet hunter by the laptop will be top of
the list
so there's about four funny things there
number one there's going to be a new
republican party if that's true i don't
think she's going to be part of it and
what i mean by that is
there's increasingly pressure within the
republican party to get the hell away
from people like marjorie taylor green
so if there's a new republican party
she'll be gone number two she talks
about all of the things committees are
going to do she's been kicked off every
committee that's also a funny thing now
of course if republicans win in the fall
they may put marjorie taylor green back
on committees that's fair but the idea
that hunter biden's laptop is going to
be a top priority i don't think she's
kidding i think she's telling the truth
and that's what makes it so scary
then she jumped into the typical
anti-semitic tropes see if you can spot
them here some of the topics you're
going to talk about
well what i'll be talking about is some
of what i've talked about right now but
i'll also be talking about how there's a
globalist agenda and that agenda is
being brought forth by the world
economic forum
klaus schwab and all of their cronies
these are the same people that you know
what they want right now is they want
war and more war because they love
crisis and they love to use it to their
political advantage now i know the
topics are going to many of our
untrained ears you might not recognize
anything she said as anti-semitic and i
concede
she may not mean these things in an
openly anti-semitic way but this is the
same old trope of
globalist
control the one guy she mentions is
jewish
for the personal gain of the people
doing the controlling often they say
klaus schwab and george soros
globalist is another buzzword sometimes
these people don't even realize
that these all of these ideas have a
basis in anti-semitism but it's marjorie
taylor green and she doesn't realize the
origins of half the things that she says
then matt gates spoke matt gates also
spoke at the rally and he says he wants
trump to be speaker of the house if
republicans win in november give us the
ability to fire nancy pelosi take back
the majority
impeach joe biden and i'm going to
nominate donald trump for speaker of the
united states house of representatives
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you everybody
[Music]
well that was interesting
yeah now again i don't think it's going
to work out for them but there is really
a movement within the republican party
to make trump speaker of the house if
they win in november remember that you
don't have to be a member of the house
to be speaker of the house anybody can
be made speaker of the house
it's just traditionally it's been a
member of the house and then we got to
a really ugly phase in the event which
is when herschel walker spoke
herschel walker who recently said
if monkeys still exist how could
evolution be real
here he is
listen to this americans we're not black
we're not white we're american we're all
mutts i hate to tell you that
we should have learned a long time ago
that 23 and me has screwed us all up
that's really the enemy guys 23 and me
and then herschel walker apparently
wanting to talk about crt critical race
theory instead talking about ctr for
this country
people want to ask me all the time while
i'm running i'm sick and tired yeah i
mean i have no idea why he's running
it's a good question i'm sick and tired
i didn't want to
teach ctr in
school
critical race theory can you tell me
what that mean
we can uh and again i i this is a guy
who's taken a lot of hits to the head he
may have a brain injury
that's not a joke i mean he played
football for a while heisman trophy
winner college football pro football um
he does seem to often be extraordinarily
confused during these speeches and ctr
that's click through rate in adver in
the world of advertising ctr
is a very important metric and maybe he
wants it taught in school and then here
is marjorie taylor green
barely able to see over the lectern
going on a very homophobic rant about
pete budage and i'll explain that to you
in a moment and you know what
pete buttig can take his electric
vehicles and his bicycles and he and his
husband can stay out of our girls
bathrooms
that is man that is so depressing
that's standard right-wing homophobic
nuttery and it's the idea that gay men
are pedophiles
why would pete buddha judge be
interested in hanging out in a girl's
bathroom it doesn't make any sense and
of course the disdain for bicycles you
don't like bicycles you don't like
electric vehicles like what is there not
to like about an electric vehicle so
this is part two of our exploration of
the rally in georgia we looked at the
trump nuttary and now the acolyte
nuttery next and lastly no more this is
the last part we will look at the
attendees
at the end of the day
no matter what trump says if he doesn't
have followers in the republican party
it doesn't really matter
but he does have followers matt gates
marjorie taylor green herschel walker
and others
but if nobody pays attention or takes
them seriously then it doesn't really
matter but unfortunately there are tens
of millions of people who love this i
hesitate to even call it a movement it's
sort of a perversion of a movement but
there are tens of millions of people and
here are a few of them who went to the
trump rally over the weekend
here is a woman who believes
things have been so bad under joe biden
that obviously everybody's going to vote
trump in 2024. specifically
so you know trump is going to have a lot
to do
a lot of work but see he's the one that
knows how to do it
and and people that
didn't vote for trump they're going to
do it this time because
they've been taught a hard lesson
yeah
a hard lesson so that's a very
optimistic trump supporter
they learned the hard way
they learned the hard way and of course
what we've learned is
trump's willing to try to steal an
election he lost in order to stay in
power ignoring all elements of democracy
and checks and balances in this country
here's just kind of a funny cringey
moment there's a guy in the audience
at the rally who wrote what he describes
as a very patriotic song
but nobody will listen to it so he
insists on giving us a few lines this
this is this is weird we're trying to
release a
patriotic song but i can't get anyone to
listen to it here
oh you guys want to hear it yeah oh
you're gonna sing it no it's a
missionary friend of mine that wrote it
uh but uh
i i played it for a few people in
houston
and uh they said they were going to get
back with me but two people in houston
said let me think about it that's not
that's not bad that's a ringing
endorsement i talk so it starts off life
liberty and truth worth uh fighting for
uh honor
love and and truth is worth dying for
and it uh mentions everything about the
great awakening but i can't get anyone
to listen to it i can't imagine why i
mean it's such he's such an inspiring
speaker and it's such a such a prescient
message that sounds like a great song
it's kind of bad no one wants to listen
to it well just everybody's busy you
know everybody's doing something you
know well how do we hear it if you just
gotta give me a card i'll send it uh
send some of them
uh i will mail you a cassette tape with
the song on it i'm continuing our tour
of the trump rally another guy at the
trump rally had a suggestion for
balancing the budget so no shortage of
economic ideas presented either ali here
how's it going sir you know how they can
how they can balance the budget
how's that drill two oil wells in alaska
and let it all go to the national budget
then we won't have no
worries about our inflation neither to
take care of it i missed the dead trump
back in there to take care of all this
biden needs to [ __ ] harris needs to
retire pelosi needs to retire schumer
and all him idioms up there
it sounds like he's saying [ __ ] but i
guess he's saying retire
um
yeah okay so he has some economic ideas
which are very very interesting and then
lastly here's a guy wearing
an american flag jacket
with an fjb that's you know f joe biden
hat on
who drove i guess to georgia from new
york and waited six hours in line now
i'm not ridiculing this
understand the level of
commitment and devotion that some of
these people have i mean i i'm the first
one to say
i don't know of anyone who would do that
to just hear joe biden speak not because
they don't support biden but because
there's not a cult like obsession with
him as an individual it's just is he
doing an okay job as president i don't
need to drive across the country to
listen to the guy i'll watch it on tv
but understand that it's important that
they have this level of commitment what
he's uh doing over there in poland right
now he's going to beat him refugees of
ukraine he's making an idiot of himself
he hasn't been to the southern border
but he's been over to ukraine exactly
pony shows
it really is it really is
so you guys from georgia okay anyway so
then the guy goes on to say he drove
there from new york and stood in line
for six hours and
et cetera et cetera
we
if we misunderstand these people
they're going to win again
it's it's just the reality of the
situation
and so it needs to be taken very
seriously and we are now it's easy to
laugh and say guys it's been almost two
years since the election they're still
saying it was stolen they still call him
president trump they still say he's
really the president and we laugh and we
point but that is a level of devotion a
cult-like devotion that
fortunately doesn't exist on the left
like you know i don't really care about
politicians from a personality
standpoint it's just like are you are
you gonna do the things you promised and
are you going to do things i agree with
that's it i'm not driving anywhere i'm
not there's no cult like interest
but this is exactly what could rocket
them back to the oval office as soon as
2024. so it should not be ignored a
dystopian horrorific
weekend in georgia
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i think and and i hope
that this will be interesting to you
i've spoken before on the show about
what i call these unsubscribed trolls
these are people who loudly tell me
sometimes for years
i was just about to become a paid member
i was just about to do it but then you
said this and now i'm never giving you a
penny or
i have been a subscriber for years but
now i'm canceling because you said the
wrong thing or whatever i have one of
these examples for you and it's kind of
evolved over several months over the
weekend an email came in from someone
named yulia
who said i'm canceling and i'm canceling
david because you were not transphobic
enough now those are my words not their
words and i looked up their email
history this is why we keep it and
hilariously they've been emailing me for
six months and it's always about how i'm
not transphobic enough i need to be more
transphobic
and it started with i was about to give
you money
but i'm not and now it's i'm canceling
because you're not transphobic this is
fascinating so let's start with the
first email this one's from early
october where yulia said hey david i've
been watching your youtube channel for
some time i was thinking about joining
to contribute money but there is one
thing that has kept me from it you see
the most attractive thing about your
channel for me i'm a molecular biologist
is you frame your narrative around
science including the vaccine debates
but there was one thing that turned me
off there was one show
in which you talked about trans people
saying something that everyone everybody
on the left tends to say trans women are
women
now as virtually any biologist will tell
you sex is real and cannot be changed by
current scientific methods in my opinion
if you're all about science saying that
trans women are women is grossly
inaccurate it's true to say trans women
are trans women but not women you're
saying that they are women because they
identify as women or whatever is
something that sounded hypocritical to
me as a biologist i would join and
support your channel i guess
if you stayed more accurate to science
because as a scientist i've been looking
for a leftist who would be true to
science guys is is yulia a scientist
i think it was only mentioned five times
in this email so first of all
i have never denied that biological sex
exists i have never claimed that current
scientific methods
chromosomally change
a man to a woman or a woman to a man but
i have said that for the purposes of
society and how i will deal with people
it makes no difference to me
whether a woman is biologically female
or not if that is how they are living
their life and want to be seen okay so
anyway you get the point that was in
october
november
yulia writes in again and says how are
you left different from trumpists david
i appreciate your show
but this recent question about
transgenderism has caught my attention
now remember they were about to
subscribe in october and didn't they're
still watching though i think you would
be doing a disservice to yourself into
the community if you continue to blindly
follow the left propaganda about
transgenderism
i know i know inclusivity so should we
for the sake of inclusivity teach
creation science in schools your show's
most prominent feature is you position
yourself as true to the facts it is what
i and most of your audience i suppose
like about you this is not the first
time julia speaks for my audience and
yulia goes on to say so tell me when a
male person says i feel i am a woman
therefore it is true and you believe him
and insist on everyone calling this male
person a female how is this different
from people saying trump won when he
didn't how is this not a delusion the
same way trumpists think trump won again
this is not tailored to the things i
have said on the show
but they are continuing to slam me and
then the final straw guy and listen
six seven months of being displeased
with what i say and continuing to watch
yulia has had enough why
unsubscribe david
i might not be significant for you
i'm just a biological scientist but i
have to say
i am unsubscribing and perhaps many
other people will follow again speaking
for everybody else the reason is i was
under the impression you were a
non-partisan objective reality czech
science channel
you betrayed me when you talk about
so-called trans people you evoke no
statistics you evoke no scientific
argument all you said was just in
agreement with youtube policy
i wish said it out loud i am saying this
because this is in agreement with
youtube policy but you didn't say that
guys i don't know what she's talking
about i have no idea
anyway yulia says i cannot recommend you
or your channel to anyone i know because
you lack integrity i am very sorry you
do not deserve a place in my media
stream
and i am a scientist you are not about
science i'm trying to i almost forgot
between emails two and three that yulia
is a scientist but now i remember anyway
i don't even know that i've said most of
the stuff she's referring to
the issue of trans people doesn't come
up a ton on this show
but you know what good riddance yulia
good riddance i was never going to be
the transphobe that you wanted me to be
so i'm sorry to see you go but not
really and hopefully this means no more
emails that's another really funny thing
sometimes people are like i haven't been
subscribed for three years
but i'm gonna email you every week with
some critique of what you said
i'm fine for you to unsubscribe but
please stop the email so that's a little
peek behind the curtain at the stuff
we're dealing with on a daily basis
donald trump has sued hillary clinton in
a very strange sprawling lawsuit that
doesn't make any sense reuters is
reporting trump sues hillary over 2016
russian collusion
allegations
donald trump on thursday sued his rival
in the 2016 election hillary clinton and
several other democrats alleging they
tried to rig that election by tying his
campaign to russia
now
what's funny about this is this is all
crazy and we'll go through it
the russia stuff
really was after trump had won
so how could you rig an elect again it's
like do you not understand time
how do you rig the 2016 election by
talking about russia in 2017.
doesn't really make sense anyway the
lawsuit covers a long list of grievances
um and comes as trump continues to
falsely claim he actually won in 2020.
acting and this is from the lawsuit
acting in concert the defendants
maliciously conspired to weave a false
narrative that their republican opponent
trump was colluding with a hostile
foreign sovereignty
the lawsuit alleges racketeering
and a conspiracy to commit injurious
falsehood
a clinton representative didn't respond
the lawsuit wants compensatory and
punitive damages trump said he was quote
forced to incur expenses and an amount
to be determined at trial
but known to be in excess of 24 million
dollars and continuing to accrue in the
form of defense cost legal fees and
related expenses do you accrue legal
fees if you don't pay them i guess sort
of
but trump often doesn't pay his uh his
lawyers another article about this
donald trump sues hillary clinton and
allies over russia claims sprawling
lawsuit accuses a large caste of
racketeering conspiracy over allegations
that trump was in putin's pocket in
2016. so listen as usual you know how
we've talked about this uh unfortunate
reality or phenomenon where the right
says hey the left is doing this and it's
actually they who are doing it
the left is going to rig the election
actually you tried to but fortunately
you failed the left can't be trusted
with classified and secret and sensitive
information actually it was you flushing
documents down the toilet taking them to
mar-a-lago spilling secrets to a russian
spy recruiter in the oval office and on
and on and on
and uh uh likewise here the right loves
to say the left is constantly suing
everybody frivolous lawsuits we've got
to deal with it tort reform and all this
stuff
isn't it time for a judge to start
holding the lawyers accountable who file
these trash lawsuits because they are
absurd
and you can be sure i mean put t take a
step back
everything else aside
you can be sure this lawsuit won't go
anywhere because if it did
the defendants
would have the ability to carry out
discovery and discovery could include up
to and including deposing donald trump
okay
maybe trump can raise money off of this
in the short term from his low
information followers maybe he can
convince them like he convinced so many
of them donate to me and i'll
fund recounts and will flip this
election and it was a lie and many of
them gave them money
maybe trump can similarly tell them give
me money so that we can sue hillary
but in the long term
this is going nowhere because trump and
his lawyers know it would be a disaster
if they were subjected to discovery
um and that's basically it this will
almost certainly be dropped soon and uh
it is another one of these
instances of do as i say not as i do and
um whatever i do by definition is right
because i'm doing it and everybody else
is lying to you and i'm telling you the
truth except i lie all the time that's
basically the bottom line here i expect
this to go absolutely nowhere we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
david p
here's an interesting voicemail about
the entire please define what a woman is
a thing including my recent appearance
on the michael knowles daily wire show
and this is another aspect to this which
is
why are these people
so obsessed with
genitalia maybe we should focus on that
take a listen
david i'm sorry i'm not done your
appearance on the michael knows show
like really triggered me
um
just this idea that he's saying that
women
you know the definition of women is the
most important thing in america you have
to push back on that make him feel like
a pervert because he's being a pervert
when he says that
you got to say
you really think whether or not a 13
year old has a penis you think what's
inside of the pants of
kids
is more important than
potential nuclear war it's more
important than north korean tests how we
respond to that it's more important to
assessing our interventions overseas and
do we send troops to ukraine what what
do we do in ukraine discussion of
kids
genitals is more important to you and
more interesting to you than foreign
policy than
domestic tranquility than literally any
other issue yeah so it's an interesting
idea which is to push back when when
they do this stuff and say
it's more applicable to the bathroom
stuff i would say than to like you know
the katanji brown jackson hearing maybe
and just the general definition of woman
but i think it's a fair thing to say
why are you so obsessed with the
genitals of kids
nobody's paying attention to that
are you saying you would if you were in
a bathroom with children it's an it's a
it's a rhetorical approach i don't think
it's super substantive but sometimes
you've got to win the rhetorical battle
so i understand thinking about it very
interesting let me know what you think
but i i have it could backfire if not
done correctly that would be the concern
we have a great bonus show for you today
we will talk about the new billionaire
tax not millionaire billionaire tax
proposed by joe biden
we will talk about a new um uh
i don't know what to call a new
initiative from uber where in new york
city
all new york taxis will be listed in the
uber app it's very interesting why this
is happening
and when pat joins me we're going to try
to figure out what happened yesterday at
the oscars where will smith
slapped chris rock and um we have some
more information about it than we did
now at the start of the show so we will
talk about that on today's bonus show
all of that and more and you can access
it instantly by signing up at
joinpacman.com
you can use the coupon code wow 22 to
get a discount we do depend on the
support of our viewers and listeners so
i would love it if you signed up at
joinpakman.com and it comes with great
perks like being able to access the
bonus show you also get a commercial
free audio and video stream of the show
every day
six hours before it is published and so
many other great perks including a
forthcoming town hall which i will tell
you more about next week see you on the
bonus show or otherwise sadly if you're
not a member we'll have to wait until
tomorrow to be together again
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagel sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get 15 off at
cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below